hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of venom versus carnage sequel
news morbius and what's going on with
the venom versus Sony they just made a
whole bunch of announcements so we got
to break it down and Jared Leto dropped
a teaser for the Morbius movie because
they're getting ready to start filming
really soon because it's Black Friday
I'll do a new round of the giveaway for
the spider-man ps4 game all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a spider-man or venom related comments
uh name a new winner at the end of this
so first big thing you probably heard
this morning that Sony just dated it's
next to Marvel movies and we know what
they are because we're getting ready to
start shooting the Morbius movie they
officially dated that for July 10th 2020
so it'll be a summer movie the year
after next so spider-man far from home
next July the summer after that will be
the Morbius movie Jared Leto just posted
this teaser to his Twitter account
because we're getting ready to start
[Music]
pretty self-explanatory they'll be more
cool behind-the-scenes stuff as they
start filming we didn't get a whole lot
of that during venom because they shot
it on such a closed stage but I think
they'll be a little bit more open with
the sequel because everyone responded to
it so well
the second Marvel movie that they just
confirmed is obviously the venom versus
carnage sequel and that is now dated for
October 2nd 2020 so just a couple months
after the Morbius movie so you can kind
of see on the way they try to stack
their spider-man venom verse movies
right now within the span of a 12 month
period Sony has five movies coming out
like really big tentpole movies with
characters that it controls including
Tom Hollands spider-man because we had
infinity war this year then we have
Avengers for next year which he'll
appear in then spider-man far from home
we had Tom Hardy in the venom movie in
October and then in December coming up
we have Spider Man into the spider verse
which is also a Sony animation movie so
you can see how they're trying to use
the Spider Man synergy of all those
separate properties together like look
at this spider-man universe
everybody get really hyped up about the
next big Spider Man thing Morbius is
just the first movie that they're doing
with a character that isn't directly
connected to spider-man
even though Morbius is largely
associated with the spider-man comics
but early scuttlebutt is is that they'll
try to work in a Tom Hardy cameo he
signed a three-picture deal but we don't
know how that incorporates cameos in the
other spin-off movies because they're
looking at is more of a venom verse than
a spider-man spider verse but the sheer
fact that they're releasing it during
the summer means that they expect that
it'll do really well usually you only
put movies in the dead of the summer
like July if you think they're gonna do
gangbusters I think the only reason for
them to release their venom verse
carnage sequel during October is just
because they had so much luck in very
little competition from other Studios
this year during October so you can see
in the boardroom now even if it's only
an OK film the lack of competition will
help it earn more money
the producers already confirmed a whole
bunch of details so I'll just break this
down top-5 style number 5 they confirmed
that it's going to be pg-13 the Morbius
movie is also going to be pg-13 no real
big surprise there they earn more money
and they can market it to a wider
audience
even though Deadpool has done in
Blee well with its r-rated films why am
I here you're in a pg-13 version of dead
Sony waited till a little bit later in
the process to back off that r-rating
well he kind of tell they shot it as an
art film then just cut it down to a
pg-13 film so number four the reason why
they're ramping up for Morbius right now
and they haven't started production yet
on the venom sequel this is because
they're spending a lot more time
developing that carnage script because
one of the biggest complaints of the
venom movie is is that was a totally a
little imbalanced the first part of the
film felt out of place with the later
parts after he got the symbiote in
everything that Tom Hardy did once he
did get the symbiote felt totally very
different from what the other actors
were doing in those scenes so it was one
of those situations where you could tell
that they were figuring out what the
movie was going to be on the fly and
they gave Tom Hardy a lot of latitude
with what he did with the character one
of my friends even got to interview him
for a junket at the movie and that's the
famous or infamous interview where he
said that there was a hours and hours of
deleted scenes that hit the cutting room
floor obviously there's a bunch of stuff
that hasn't made the movie and I think
I'm talking as an actor point of view so
what I'm saying is is that I had a lot
of time improvising and a lot of freedom
to play with venom okay so in honesty
there's probably about seven hours or
more with the footage of me playing as
venom and enjoying myself to the mate
but most of that was all improv of him
trying to figure out the Eddie venom
relationship so like when he does really
funny stuff like when he climbed in the
lobster tank that's just something that
he came up with in the moment that was
not in the script usually what they do
with a lot of sequels like spider-man
far from home for instance is that once
you figured the character out like they
know who Tom Hollands spider-man is you
know how he would act it's a lot easier
to write scenes for him but that also
plays into the idea of number three
Woody Harrelson as the Cletus Kasady
carnage character everybody saw that
post-credit scene it was way over the
top the red wig was terrible you could
tell they kind of threw it together at
the last minute really late in the
process that early tracking for the film
wasn't doing so well so I think that
Sony was still planning on doing a
sequel no matter what even if the film
didn't do as well as it did and it did
do very well
director Ruben Fleischer was also the
director of the zombie land movies so
that's the Woody Harrelson connection
he's the one that brought him in and I
feel like Woody Harrelson does crazy
really well but I think they have to
give him the right material and that
just goes into them spending more time
working on that scripts because Cletus
Kasady crazy is very different from Tom
Hardy climbing into a lobster tank crazy
too they confirmed that his origin story
as carnage will be a little bit
different from the comics but no more
different than Venom's origin story was
different from the comics so obviously
they didn't do Secret Wars they didn't
do spider-man with Tom Holland they
actually did do quite a bit of the
animated series where J jonah Jameson's
son crashes the spaceship they actually
had his son as a character in the film
so there were a lot of Easter eggs for
the spider-man story - all the Peter
Parker spider-man stuff but in that same
way I've already talked about the
original comic book origin for the
carnage character they kind of give you
an idea for what they're doing with that
with this interview in the post-credits
scene he goes in continues to interview
him there's an escape attempt in the
chaos the Venom symbiote spawns the
spawn bonds with Cletus Kasady and then
they break out and then Eddie learns
later what's going on like wait a minute
why are all these blood spatter messages
at the crime scenes this is definitely
Cletus Cassidy's calling card but it
looks so much more vicious and powerful
like one of the symbiotes and as at the
end of the movie venom thinks that it's
the only symbiote that's left on planet
earth big surprise the carnage is the
offspring of the Venom symbiote so you
have sort of like this montage where
Eddy learns a little bit more about the
biology of symbiotes he really doesn't
know that much about them only that
they're from another planet they're
called the Clint are in the symbiote
calls itself kind of a loser
among its own people like it doesn't
tell him anything else about how they
reproduce asexually or anything like
that so the Venom symbiote were to spawn
while he was in the prison near Cletus
Kasady Eddie wouldn't realize what was
going on just like a piece of it was
slough off like oh what's wrong are you
sick then that later surprise surprise
the carnage symbiote bonds with Cletus
Kasady and you have your movie number
one for those of you asking what's going
on with spider-man Tom Holland though
Sony does have to renew its sharing
arrangement after this spider-man far
from home film next year but Tom Holland
already did an interview confirming that
they're doing a third film
this is that clip there is still a lot
of room for Peter Parker and spider-man
especially to grow in the next two
movies you know he's definitely not the
finished article by the end of
spider-man homecoming and I really look
forward to exploring the different ways
that he can grow up and go through
puberty I guess and yeah it's gonna be
an exciting couple movies and you said
two movies it means I'm coming two and
three I think yeah there'll be
spider-man 2 and three it won't be
homecoming three and mostess Cooper
because we knew her but the second one
but not the third one yeah well now you
know what that means is is that Marvel
and Sony originally had plans to do a
trilogy of Tom Holland films but they
only signed a deal up to spider-man far
from home early predictions since venom
was such a financial success Sony will
try to get a bigger piece of the
merchandising pie from Marvel because
right now Marvel doesn't earn any money
from the box office that Sony gets from
its Tom Hollands spider-man solo films
but they do get 100% of all the
merchandising which can sometimes be way
more money than you would ever earn on a
movie in a theater Marvel will probably
just try to lock down a longer deal but
everybody let me know in the comments
what are you most hyped up about for the
Morbius movie for the venom sequel
congratulations blaziken blast you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
details click here to rewatch that new
Deadpool Christmas trailer and click
here to learn what's going on with the
Avengers 4 trailer in the official
marvel timeline thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you